did you see mike tyson talk about dr
umar johnson on his podcast do you know
who dr umar johnson is no he's about to
be your favorite guy
is he like a black israelite kind of
yeah it's a little different yeah he's
the prince of pan-africanism
awesome and uh
this
he's the perfect example of how like
just because someone doesn't like you
doesn't mean you don't like them
you know what i mean like i i understand
that he might not like me because i'm
white
right and i'm part of the systemic
racism that's baked into america but
i love him
yes like i absolutely he's the most
entertaining speaker on instagram right
now
remember when chris rock would like kind
of stalk the stage and repeat premises
yeah he opens up his instagram like
lives so
it's unbelievable i'm not even gonna do
it just can we like bring up i see a
picture of him because i think i know
who he is
is he big
yeah he's from philly oh i know this guy
yeah this guy rules oh dude he's the i
built the whole plan i ain't going
nowhere
but i appreciate the concern my
beautiful african queen i hope your hair
is natural
baby i see you got that perm in there i
still love you you're gorgeous but
you're not nappy you got to be nappy
baby you got to be nappy
i can't grab it i can't have it it only
takes a little bit
of white brainwash to activate the cool
chip
heterosexual couples only
this is not a government-funded activity
i have the right to discriminate
heterosexual couples only
donations
gifts
yes
[Music]
we're gonna have a national coons
conference at fdmgs brothers and sisters
we have to have a national coons
conference anybody who tells you they're
running for office to help somebody
smack their ass in the face what you
want to do you want a box thing you want
a street rumble or you want to get into
the intellectual boxing ring
tyler perry god damn brother can we
please
consider
some other
movies
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is the he's so [ __ ]
undeniably entertaining i don't care who
he hates or who he likes it means
nothing to me
i agree it is just and i'm looking i'm
sitting there looking at and i'm sitting
here going like i mean he stands for
like a lot of like [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up
like easy you know gay couples
against interracial marriage against
interracial marriage like there's
certain things that you know we disagree
with
[Laughter]
um but yeah but in all seriousness um
he's he's [ __ ] brilliant and i love
him
and i really want him on this podcast
but what did mike tyson say about him oh
that was it yeah tyson was talking [ __ ]
no no uh freddie gibbs was on tyson's
podcast and then he just brought up dr
umar and he was like yeah you don't
really like white people that much and
then tyson's like why does he like white
people like what's wrong with that
that's that's the worst tyson i've ever
heard bro
well he no longer speaks with the hey oh
he doesn't oh he's like so like on like
he's like mushroomed out and like high i
apologize but he's almost like raspy and
[ __ ] yeah yeah you guys watching guys
he's still got that there but yeah it's
not what he uses oh yeah it's weird
really yeah
take it back
there's a little bit it's actually kind
of sad like if you guys watch it like
every time i see a clip he's just so
[ __ ] out of here he's like a tiger on
tranquilizers yeah yeah
and i don't want to criticize you know
the people behind it but it's almost
like on some like britney spears [ __ ]
it's like does he want to be up there
yeah free mic bro we might have to free
mind
dog
is he the most forgiving rapist ever
yeah
well bill clinton
well he never got convicted
he paid him off
he never got no i think we feel the
opposite way about them i think with
bill we're like i know he didn't get
convicted but he probably did that [ __ ]
and when mike were like he got convicted
but he probably ain't doing this yeah i
don't think anybody else burgers up
there oh we're talking we're talking
about
something you should know something true
true uh who else
depends what community
i mean how many people convicted
i was gonna say michael jackson but no
tupac didn't tupac
go out for sexual assault yes yeah and
then nobody brings that [ __ ] up ever
yeah that's because he got killed
but he even got a star
rushing [ __ ] under the rug really i
think so yeah
but yeah tyson for sure he had a show on
[ __ ] adult swim he the cartoon yeah
the most liberal people on earth were
like yeah mike tyson yeah yeah what do
you think that is
uh he's black
what do you want me to say no like i
think there's something more for the
adult swimming people to take him that's
what i was saying yeah
not the forgiveness of the sexual
assault
interesting
i don't know i think that tyson is like
beyond a race
i think we also are so aware of the [ __ ]
he went through now that we're like i
guess give him some grace do you think
he's ascended do you think he's like oj
i think he's like will smith
like will smith isn't like black guy
he's will smith
and i think tyson isn't black guys
we didn't take them they're white no no
they're so famous that they're white no
they're just themself
you know what i mean and i think i
wonder if white guys can do that too
like if white guys can stop like for
example the rock nobody knows what the
rock is because he's the rock yeah
even though even the kardashians they're
not really like white white
but they're just so big that they're
just they're just kardashes when you
become the greatest at your thing you
just are you yeah
and that is the advantage of being white
is you never have to leave that other
identity that defines you completely
yeah you just said i was going to say we
don't look at george clooney as not
having a race because like well he's
always just been white and successful
and that's what it is yeah
you just get to be your identity when
you're part of the majority you just get
to be your identity that you create in
front of people he didn't have to like
escape a box or whatever mm-hmm
yeah george clooney we've always been
george clinton yeah will smith we saw as
this black dude had his own tv show was
a rapper and then it just he got bigger
and bigger and he's like oh nice will
smith yeah and apparently he would like
pick roles
apparently it was like a formula like
we're going to do this kind of movie
than this kind of movie than this kind
of movie but specifically the removed
race from the role
interesting like he's like
you see bagger vance
no
he's probably inside a movie about a not
sport he's pretty black in that one yeah
yeah yeah yeah no of course he's going
to be black in all the [ __ ] movies
but he's not playing like this is a
stereotypical it was the one like
one movie i wish he had considered race
when he took that one because it's like
the way you're doing this buddy i know
how you thought there's no race involved
but looking like you look
being a [ __ ] caddy yeah there's some
race involved all right fair enough i
didn't see that one but you know the
rest you probably picked it thinking
this is just a good script yeah it would
be the [ __ ] neo in the matrix yeah
that would have been cool
yeah
yeah i think keanu i mean maybe you're
just like hindsight i think keanu needed
to be that guy that's all kind of like
spaced out and like unaware of what's
happening i think will smith would have
been too cool yeah maybe will smith
would have been cool though
as neo yeah yeah yeah but he'd be too
like funny and charming
that has got to be weird and spacey
that's what i'm saying will smith is
like he's the coolest [ __ ] in
the room men in black was even though he
was like kind of a dummy he was still
[ __ ] cool yeah you know what i mean
and neo wasn't isn't supposed to be that
guy i don't think yeah but yeah maybe
we're just looking at it now the movie
we love has to be this way
yeah but he also turned down he did he
did no matrix so he could do wow wow
west i think yes yeah what a [ __ ]
move and then
he turned down inception he turned down
the queen tarantino django
because he wanted to kill i'm glad that
that's yeah
yeah jamie killed that yeah but that's
the thing it's like when you're that
when you're the guy you get offered
every movie
yeah that's true at least it gets
floated
it'll get floated it might not be like
an actual like deal but you'll get like
brought up like oh yeah we got this
person in a meeting like it will be
i bet you it's even a deal if it's a big
big budget movie like that like i bet
you ever who is it i think chris rock
even said like every year they want tom
hanks the oscars
right and he says no and then how many
people need to see no before i do it
right but like every year you want the
main guy yeah and he was the main guy so
every movie you're like yeah i think
will smith can probably [ __ ] well i
know django formula
will smith dicaprio will smith
so even leo
you know like you know like if you get
like a spot somewhere you'll get like a
weekend somewhere because someone built
somebody dropped out even leo goes
through that yeah
in order for you to do a weekend of
[ __ ] hyenas or something like that i
remember i was doing weekend height and
some would bail like you come in a week
before and then the club's [ __ ] upset
that you don't sell tickets yeah i was
like yeah you had brad garrett on the
poster
at the club [ __ ] there's no way we're
gonna sell [ __ ] tickets but that's
leo had got to go through that [ __ ] to
do inception
the fact that you said brad garrett let
me know that's a real story
it might have been brad garrett dude
because nobody ever thinks of brad
garrett
bro i didn't
he lowers it for the show oh he does
it's a little bit higher for okay in
real life then he lowered it for the
show he killed that [ __ ] that's one of
the better stand-ups in a sitcom like
normally they're not good at being
someone else or just themselves he
played that [ __ ] very well i didn't know
he's a stand about shocked it was a
stand up